[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing one of the fastest objects
in the harry potter universe it's not a
dragon it's not a snitch
and it's not a cornish pixie it's the
fire bolt
now we hear of a few different brooms
name dropped throughout the books and
films
perhaps most notably in one of the
beginning sequences
of the philosopher's stone when hagrid
takes harry to diagon alley
when they walk past the broom shop
children are gawking at a brim through
the window
whoa look at it the new nimbus 2000
henry overhears as he walks by
and while the nimbus 2000 was an
impressive broom of its time
it wasn't long before it was
overshadowed later being eclipsed by the
performance
of the nimbus 2001 however as you can
guess
with advancing technology it wasn't long
before even the nimbus 2001
was eclipsed in performance along comes
the fire bolt
fire bolts are exceptionally well made
and lightning fast broomsticks
said to be capable of achieving speeds
upwards of 150 miles per hour
not only that but they have a ton of
special features including the
unbreakable
braking charm and goblin made iron work
which both help with power and stability
the broom was produced by brim maker
randolph spudmore in 1993
and when harry first saw a firebolt in
the window of quality quidditch supplies
before his third year he wanted one
desperately harry of course eventually
receives one as a gift from his
godfather
sirius black but that doesn't erase the
fact that harry was unwilling to pay for
one himself
marry in spite of his vault full of gold
still gawked at the price which begs the
question
how expensive were these things for the
descendant of fleemont potter to
question the price
we must be talking some serious cash
harry ripped the parcel open
and gasped as a magnificent gleaming
broomstick rolled out onto his bed
spread
ron dropped his socks and jumped off his
bed for a closer look
i don't believe it he said horsley it
was a firebolt
identical to the dream room harry had
gone to see every day in diagon alley
its handle glittered as he picked it up
he could feel it vibrating
and let go it hung in mid-air
unsupported
at exactly the right height for him to
mount it who sent it to you
said ron in a hushed voice look and see
if there's a card said harry
ron ripped apart the firebolt's
wrappings nothing
blimey who'd spend that much on you now
we know the answer to ron's question
it was serious black but what we don't
know is how much
that much is so let's dive in the first
thing that we need to consider is that
harry when first looking at the glorious
brum
implies that buying one would nearly
empty his gringotts fault
however i'm willing to bet that harry's
statement here was largely
hyperbole sort of like how people say
that would cost a fortune
don't get me wrong i don't think the
firebolt was cheap by any means
but maybe not expensive to the extent
that it would empty the vault of a
wealthy young wizard
fortunately for us there is one clue
that gives us some insight into the cost
of the firebolt
when harry first receives the broom ron
suggests that the firebolt might be a
gift from dumbledore
and to which harry replies the
dumbledore wouldn't spend
hundreds of galleons on a firebolt for
him this narrows down the cost of a
firebolt immediately
as now we should be able to reasonably
deduce that it costs anywhere between
200 and 999 gallons if i had to guess
i would theorize that the cost of a
fireball broom would be approximately
30 to 40 times the cost of a wizarding
staple such
as a wand from what i can tell most
things in the wizarding world are paid
for
in lesser currency like sickles or
canads
though there are certainly objects that
cost galleons most
day-to-day objects utilize these lesser
currencies
harry potter's 1 cost him 7 gallons and
if we apply my theory of
30 to 40 times the cost of a wand the
fire bolt would be somewhere between 210
and 280 gallons this means the firebolt
would have cost harry approximately
fifteen hundred
to two thousand dollars or eleven
hundred to fourteen hundred pounds
this price in my eyes works well with
harry's socio-economic status and his
perception of currency as just a young
man
what do you guys think of this theory
what do you think the fire bolt cost
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
bad times like that bring out the best
in some people and the worst in others
[Music]